all right guys
bang bang i'm super excited for this
episode i've got chamira here thank you
so much for doing this sir
my pleasure man very happy to be here
absolutely uh
you obviously have an accent you're
living in australia right now
uh let's go back though before we get to
all the fun stuff
uh who are you where did you grow up and
kind of what's your background before
you get to amnesty international
yeah absolutely man um so yeah as you
said definitely a strong aussie accent
i've um i've
born and raised in australia um and uh
i'm working at amnesty international at
the moment my background
um in general has been i did a human
rights
law degree at university which certainly
put me on the path
for um you know getting involved and
furthering human rights and the
international space i would say
uh in general with a little bit of
politics international relations thrown
in
um and then i had a big focus being like
a relationship management
in recruitment um did that for many
years
and uh was a little bit uh unfulfilled
towards the end and i was looking for a
way to connect my my sort of passions
and areas of interest and
skills um and it led me to amnesty
international which was
obviously um you know a huge
international organization
working on all the causes that i care
about some in particular i would say
um and it's uh it led me to where i am
today
what is amnesty international for those
that don't know
amnesty is the it's the largest uh human
rights organization in the world it's
been around since 1961
um started by a human rights lawyer
named peter beninson
um who who was basically raising a toast
to freedom
um and wanted to ensure that people
around the world
could you know condemn any acts that
jeopardize human rights
that took place around the world by
sending letters predominantly
from there amnesty's growing to 150
countries
um about just over 10 million supporters
uh around the world and
has grown in influence with governments
with with people um
speaking up for people who don't um who
can't amplify their concerns or have
been mistreated around the world
uh they generally look to amnesty as a
bit of a independent pillar
to to stand up for human rights and and
protect them
one of the cases that uh you've been
involved in is the julian assange
kind of story and this goes back many
years uh
people who are listening to this some of
them will be experts on the details and
some will be beginners
maybe just walk us through who is julian
assange and why has
um his story become so publicly known
and
uh has so many people kind of paying
attention absolutely
so as we were saying earlier you know
it's it's it's one of the most
complicated
cases um and back stories is certainly
important and
and i think putting it all together in
an easy to digest way is super important
for people to actually understand why
it's important particularly your weekend
from
what i would say is one of the biggest
trials and verdicts of our time in terms
of his backstory
julian um uh is a publisher uh
julian uh is a journalist he basically
um performed activities that many
journalists
performed today and and have for a very
long time which is receiving information
from different sources uh and then
publishing it on a platform which he
created which i believe started in about
2006 called wikileaks which many people
would have heard of
um you know the role that wikileaks
played in in broader society and and
particularly in the
media journalism space has been pretty
profound uh but what he did basically
was
um in a sense uh you know publish
information directly straight from the
horse's mouth i would say
so that it basically got around any
inherent biases that took place when
reporting from journalists or media orgs
which
you know like any organization pretty
plenty of pros and cons
but certainly there can be vested
interests there can be
inherent bias there can be slants put in
in the reporting of information and once
again
information is the grounding for which
we all make our judgments on the world
uh how we think how we vote ultimately
so
for that to be as transparent and and
and you know um
clear as possible you the more raw the
information the better
uh obviously keeping in line with
national security
i'm not putting anyone at risk etc so
with that in mind
um wikileaks published information
including emails
um you know and uh and various uh
reports that they believe in the public
interest which makes us more informed
uh today and so his background was
predominantly publishing his
his um experience prior to that i
believe was in uh
tech um and software and i.t but that's
certainly what shaped his um
yeah his career and so obviously
wikileaks
uh has become you know a known quantity
on an international stage
uh there's a lot of sensitive
information some would argue
confidential some would argue
uh is important for the public light and
kind of public conversation
what is the type of content like are
there specific examples that stick out
into your head that were kind of
milestone uh type publishing um or
leaks that wikileaks posted so people
can get a sense of what that content is
absolutely i think the ones that stood
out the most and the ones that are
referred to the most
um you know in general are the iraq war
logs is what they were called
in 2010 um there was there was a release
of many cables um as they were called
and also
a video in particular which many people
may be aware of the apache
helicopter and uh gunning down
civilians um including uh reporters
themselves and
the nature that it was done and and uh
the sort of crassness in how that that
action was performed was
was shocking to people around the world
um a lot of people suspect
this takes place uh in wars and you know
it is a war
um and uh no one gets to really see the
the details unless you're on the ground
and i think we're kind of covered here
in the
in the west and i think that for many
people was that was the
um sort of anchor for wow you know
that's good to know i didn't know this
was being performed in our names
uh as the public the guantanamo bay
prisoner um files as well as to how they
were being treated 2007 i believe was
um another big one which would shape
people's perceptions
um there was a lot of emails um
regarding uh the the dnc in america
um treatment of of bernie sanders
um and and the voting within the party
itself
um and conversations that took place so
i won't get into the absolute details
but um
yeah it certainly revealed uh aspects of
um you know uh governments and
institutions that we place a lot of
trust in
uh and and made it a lot clearer as to
how they act
on on a regular basis and that's really
important
um for us again to make our mind up to
be informed citizens
and uh and know what what what world
we're operating and
and sort of playing in yeah yeah and i
think part of it was like
one half of the population was surprised
by all of this and frankly shocked
uh and then another half it just
confirmed what their you know greatest
fears or or
kind of the conspiracy type uh viewpoint
was right i was just like i always
thought this happened but like okay now
there's proof
so it really you know pulled a lot of
folks in and then obviously those that
are in powerful positions or positions
of influence
uh this wasn't exactly the type of
information that they wanted to
be publicly exposed um you know in a
bunch of different forms and factions
uh so julian assange doing journalistic
work
uh today has been arrested uh in the
united states
there is the belief that there's the
freedom of press there's a lot of
nuance there's a lot of legal precedent
that
shapes that view in the united states uh
how do we get from the publication of
confidential or
sensitive information via wikileaks in a
journalistic
type perspective to him sitting behind
bars today like
what is that path uh and maybe talk
through a little bit
in terms of julian's perspective and
then those who might disagree with his
perspective
fair enough yeah um it's been a bit of a
long road i would say a lot of
um factors have come come to play and
all which kind of need
unpacking in their own way so um after
the war logs
um he was actually uh in sweden and this
is quite a controversial
um you know aspect as well which which
kind of um framed how he was perceived
publicly but
um you know my understanding is there
were allegations of
rape charges in sweden which he uh faced
up to in terms of a um
an online hearing or on it was like one
of the first extradition
processes that he had to go through um
charges were dropped and and the case
was was dropped
um it was reopened in future i think
many years later
um due to some encouragement um but
during that time he felt that
um there was a concerted effort uh to
get him to
to um uh you know to the us that
ultimately
based on his actions and publications
the us
will want to get him and that that
that's fairly logical that obviously
you know i can't imagine them wanting to
just let the guys see it so
you know um they they um
there was a connection there with london
as well so to try and get him to
um face up in london and exactly the
scenario that's taking place now which
is actually an extradition treaty
between the us and and the uk uh
for him to be um trialled in in london
in the uk and then be sent to the to the
us
the nature of what that would look like
wasn't clear but that was the general
suspicion
um so he was actually treated as
uh an asylum seeker which is which is
not the term you'd normally think of
with um with this instance um but there
were many countries that that felt that
his he was being chased after
um you know and and for the wrong
reasons
and that it was unjust and so a number
of countries around the world offered
him um
asylum or refuge uh and ecuador being
one of them
so whilst being in london the ecuadorian
embassy
in london granted him uh that refuge
and so he spent a lot of time there i
believe it was uh
you know seven to eight years he spent
in in ecuador
with them saying you are persecuted
individual
we recognize your actions and the
treatment uh that that you've um
you know experienced and that there's a
general consensus that the us will want
to get you and mistreat you further
um you know to kind of narrow it down so
he spent a lot of time there he was
still performing
wikileaks actions whilst in the embassy
um
and you know from the us and uk
perspective i can imagine that would be
um you know particularly when he would
be revealing uh actions that they were
purporting i can imagine they wouldn't
be too happy and would still be trying
to
um get him to let's say face the music
based on their own terms whether it was
right or wrong um and
as an international community as a human
rights organization with amnesty
there was certainly an acknowledgment
that that was that was wrong
that was breaking a number of human
rights
laws um and that it would set a really
bad precedent for future journalists um
you know and and publishers around the
world um
who wanted to perform similar actions in
the public's interest
and that he was being used as a
scapegoat now that
uh has come to be um so last year would
probably be one of the most important
years in this whole story
and unfolding because he was um
literally
um given up i would say by the
ecuadorian
um embassy um and then
physically dragged uh out and taken to
belmarsh prison in london okay before
before we continue
uh i want to clarify a couple of things
so
julian assange is in london uh feels
like kind of the walls are
closing in around him he is likely to
continue to face
legal obstacles potentially arrest uh
there's all kinds of allegations
that are levied against him i don't want
to go into uh
whether they are um you know guilty not
guilty
the courts around the world will figure
that stuff out uh but there was
definitely allegations
um some of them were uh not that you
know
shocking or damning and some of them
were really really bad right so there's
a whole spectrum there
uh but at some point he realizes i need
to
find asylum with a country that is
willing to treat me like a refuge
um talk through and so what he
ultimately does is he
literally walks into the ecuadorian
embassy in london
and stays there for years um and kind of
has this
refuge talk through what does asylum
mean like when somebody is looking for
asylum
just at a high level for those that
don't understand it when he walks into
that door
why is he safe even though he is
technically in the city of london but he
is now in an ecuadorian building and how
that works
yeah absolutely i mean in terms of
asylum it's um you know it's basically
um
an unfounded fear of persecution based
on a number of factors it could be
religious it could be
um you know your your sexuality could be
um you know a variety and basically if
anyone falls under those factors they're
considered
a refugee and should be granted asylum i
don't know the act
the absolute specifics of of that
instance and how it was defined
but they did consider that he was a
political prisoner
and somebody whose life was at risk from
from governments um
based on actions he performed they
believed weren't illegal whatsoever
um and this also kind of fell into the
narrative
of assange being a a hacker
which you know which was part of the
trial that he's facing at the moment um
and where there has been no proof
uh whatsoever that's the case and again
it's another word that you can
you know slap on to someone as a label
and it just kind of sticks
and then um there's no second thought
but um yeah so without him being a
hacker
there was there was certainly grounds to
say that he was being persecuted and so
asylum um it's basically an entity of
the ecuadorian
state uh in london and he's based on
international law protections
um he he is allowed to to um
to reside there and and not be touched i
would suppose unless there was
extenuating circumstances where
that embassy decided you know what uh
we're gonna cancel this
uh this refuge regardless of how that
internationally plays between
us and other countries um because there
were staunch
staunch advocates of him being protected
and i believe there was a change in
government
in ecuador i believe um carrera
i think was the initial um leader that
granted him
asylum and as there was a change in
future um
there was also a bit of a change of tone
towards the end of that so coming up to
last year
where there are a number of reports of
asanda's activities taking place
in the embassy itself that they felt
weren't appropriate and they decided to
give him up let's say there was a hefty
um loan given to to ecuador not long
after that took place as well in the
billions so that's an interesting one to
look into
but that aside um yeah there was a lot
of activities that also took place just
to clarify within the embassy
uh such as spying so there was spying of
all the guests that came into the
embassy in the bathrooms
there was spying on his um legal
proceedings which in many countries if
that took place it'd be like see you
later that's it you know we're not going
to continue this
that was considered recently and taken
into account which was good
but again shouldn't happen so it was
quite a
interesting space going on there there
was reports of bugging
uh plenty of evidence even
whistleblowers that worked there said
that there was a lot of things going on
that just wasn't appropriate
so it was quite an interesting time
towards the end um and then he was given
up to london who took him into
so while he's got the um uh
kind of the asylum he's there he's
protected for a number of years what
stops the
london police the fbi you know pretty
much anyone with big guns and a lot of
men from kicking down the door and just
going and taking them like what is the
uh the reason why they don't do that is
it a respect for international law or is
it something else is it that the ecuador
will
literally shoot guns from armed guards
to
protect the embassy like how does that
work yeah it is though it is respect for
um international law which um
a lot of countries kind of play with to
their own advantage to be honest but
it's more of like an international
consensus and agreement so um you know
there are there are conventions
the refugee convention for example the
rights of child
like there are a variety that countries
subscribe to
um you know uh and and they have to
sort of stick to it but there has been
instances of countries that just kind of
scared around at different times to suit
their own agendas
um in this instance it would be that i
think it would be just far too blatant
to come in storming
as i mentioned it's been a very long
process where um you know
the action look the right actions had to
kind of um
play out at the right time it's not like
you could just go in willy-nilly
storm the place it would be a huge
breach and i don't think
um you know in my own mind sort of um
guessing how it would work i don't think
the us would think that it would be
worth for a case like this to go that
far
because of how they would be perceived
on an international scale um
so yeah it's really to keep the peace
more than anything and adhere to those
international human rights standards um
so that uh yeah
i think like i said they pick and choose
the case to kind of um skirt around
and so at some point uh julian assange
is doing
whatever he's doing inside of the
building uh again there's a bunch of
debate
good bad and different uh then the
ecuadorian government there's this
change of power
uh but we eventually get to the point
where ecuador now says you know what
you no longer are going to have this
asylum uh and
my understanding and correct me if i'm
wrong here is like they literally just
call the london police and they're like
come get them like literally we're just
gonna open the front door and like
come drag them out is that is that what
happens correct yeah that was pretty
much
when it was pretty um at that point it
was pretty um
brash and in your face i suppose but
that and that's where the famous shot
a lot of people would have seen came
from with him kind of being dragged out
like
with a beard as you can tell he has
probably hasn't been living in the best
conditions and put into a van and then
just quite simply taken
uh away um for further hearings and then
put into belmar and just to clarify bill
marsh is
one of the worst prisons in england
anyone you talk to says
you know it's it's extremely rough and
the fact that someone
um assigned and and the actions he's
performed is in belmar is just
so out outlandish and ridiculous that um
it's a statement in itself
so yeah and and when he
gets arrested i'll kind of put that into
air quotes because i don't know if
that's actually how they've
you know labeled this uh but when that
occurs
what are the charges against them are
these new charges
are these simply the application of
previous uh
allegations against him how does he kind
of
end up behind bars or what's the
rationale there
yeah the rationale is um so
uh there was a number of things so with
the trial itself
um they were one of the biggest focus
points was what i mentioned before about
hacking and whether he was
um conspiring to hack information so for
example chelsea manning was obviously
many people would know as a
whistleblower that um passed on
from the inside many documents um which
wikileaks then published again an action
that
new york times you know many other
papers would do
um but but to get him on that sort of
technicality was did he
conspire to hack this information did he
conspire to say look i will help you
hack this
i will illegally ascertain this
information and again from the
the case notes that i've seen and not
many people have seen it doesn't seem to
be any evidence of that
another one was that he um skipped bail
um in london so that was another
technicality and again
you know um this kind of all falls into
the context
of there was a genuine fear that the
exact scenario that's playing out right
now was going to happen
and people said that's ridiculous you
know you've got to face up etc etc and
um yeah there's certainly a legal
process that has to take place but
all those fears you know have come to
fruition
um and and to add on to that was whether
um anyone was
um harmed from from his releases so did
anyone
um you know get physically um harmed
from their names being revealed in any
publications
which also ties into the um questioning
from a lot of people about how
he isn't a journalist because he didn't
retract names
um we've seen more than enough evidence
i think a week ago there was an
hour-long chat between him and the
government saying look
i've just been up till 4am deleting as
many names as i possibly can many
witnesses have proven that
guardian journals as well saying
not he literally didn't sleep to make
sure there were no names
involved that no one was implicated and
again we're talking millions of cables
so you do the absolute best you possibly
can
whilst balancing the story that you're
trying to put forward so
um yeah again i haven't seen any
evidence evidence of that
um throughout this trial but they were
the main points got it and so
what is the difference between what
julian assange did and
let's say the new york times washington
post p you know organizations that
people consider mainstream media that um
you know conduct journalism and most
people would think
that uh if there is confidential or
sensitive information that they got
their hands on they would publish and
they would tell the stories and kind of
hold
people of power influence or
organizations accountable
uh what is the difference between
assange and any of those organizations
well it's a really good question um you
know and this is probably
the best way to um to ground this whole
this whole conversation is
you know obama had the opportunity to
um prosecute assange and he said i can't
and many people are asking you know why
and it was called the
new york times problem or predicament
because
he said if i prosecuted julian assange i
would then have to prosecute the new
york times because
so many of these papers perform the
exact same function if
he's quite simply a publisher not even
in the u.s it's not even
in the country uh and he's just re he's
like a middleman really is revealing
information for people to consume
um there actually isn't any difference
to be honest and
i think there are certainly journalists
that think that um you know the way he
he went about publishing information
didn't make him a journalist and
now we're getting into the
technicalities of an industry where
certain players might think one thing
culturally the others might think now
that's that's a good culture that's a
bad culture
so um top line overall like there wasn't
any dispute
which also has had to be proven and
chipped away out over time
to unpack the stereotype and stigma that
was put forward
by the media funnily enough that that
also
um um made so many stories off the back
of wikileaks publications we have to
remember
um so they've profited they've they've
gotten plenty of clicks and readers from
from a lot of wikileaks stories but then
when the tide shifted one of the first
to kind of
to shift and turn their back on on
assange and again
i i completely acknowledge it's an
extremely complicated case it's not
black and white
like like many things aren't black and
white there's a lot of space in the gray
that has to be unpacked to truly
understand
so i think with with this instance
there's enough evidence to say he
absolutely is a journalist the same as
many different publications
um and the manner in which he went about
it could be the
slight difference which for me is a
cultural thing of an industry
would there have been a difference if
let's say uh julian assange simply said
hey i've built a website
if you have confidential sensitive
information that you would like to leak
upload it i'm actually not going to look
at it and it's just going to auto
publish
in some way he now isn't taking like
quote unquote editorial control
or you know uh redacting names and kind
of there's a whole bunch of downsides to
that model
uh but would that have been less risky
for him
like would he basically have been able
to insulate himself
from uh some of the pressures and
ultimately the arrest uh by simply just
saying hey i built a website and anyone
can use it but
i don't actually say publish this pub
don't you know don't publish that
yeah that's a good question as far as
i'm aware i mean i
i understand i mean wikileaks is a
website um
and uh you know they they also one of
the first to
um have a dropbox that um whistleblowers
or anyone
could just put information into so if
you didn't feel comfortable passing this
on to other
organizations or other parties you could
literally put it into the dropbox
wikileaks would ascertain it
protect your identity and then publish
um but as for
as far as i understand it was quite
similar to that i think
i don't know if he was called an editor
per se um
but certainly the the sort of figurehead
of this of this
you know you could call it a publication
because it was um
compiling information and then just
putting it out there through their own
through their own channels and
and again um it was very much
in you know um in line with the
internet's culture at the time i suppose
which is
we've got this big chunk of data this
big chunk of information we're going to
put it out there and you can sift
through it in your own time
so um you know and that's probably where
that like i mentioned before that sort
of conversation of oh is that a
journalistic practice but once again
to be honest i was way more informed and
many people were more informed reading
it directly rather than
reading someone's interpretation um so i
think it was quite similar to be honest
yeah and to be clear normally if
somebody had taken that information and
not sent it to julian assange and
wikileaks they had sent it to the new
york times washington post whatever
uh some of it would be quote unquote
verified
right but once that had been done they
basically would reveal the same
information they just might write their
own story and then insert their own
opinions or
facts or details you know not
necessarily quote
fake news but just they would tell a
story around the information they would
never just
dump it in terms of hey come and read it
but i think what you're getting at here
is like
is actually just revealing the source
materials
a better journalistic practice because
now it allows the reader to make up
their own mind after reading the content
rather than
having to rely on the journalist or the
organization to be that filter
that basically tells the story and can
use
data or information to weave into a
story to craft a narrative versus just
seeing the actual information for
yourself right
yeah correct and look i think um you
know again there's that there's that
nuance and the grey
uh aspect of journalism because i mean
it's a fantastic profession it's
extremely valuable i i was looking to be
a journalist when i was younger as well
um you know and i i really thought that
it was such an it plays such an
important role in society and it
absolutely does and journalism takes on
many forms
you know there's a lot of value in
reading the source material if you want
to be informed than an issue
but then what about the 10 to 20
different forms of journalism that give
you like
you know uh a nice little blog or a
narrative or a backstory to something or
an opinion piece like like everything
pros and cons
um but when it comes to certain types of
information that source material
when it's uncompromised and it's just
again straight from the horse's mouth
um i feel makes you more informed and
there are some issues that
probably shouldn't really be you know
shouldn't really go through that filter
because they're the issues that are
really important for you to know before
you vote or make your mind up about the
world around you
um and uh yeah so i think that you know
there's um
it takes many forms definitely pros and
cons and benefits to each side but
um having that source material is just
invaluable
so let's talk about moving forward uh
julian assange is currently
under arrest uh i believe there's an
extra extra edition
uh interest i don't know if that's like
a request or whatever but basically the
united states would like to bring him to
the united states
uh it sounds like there's some legal
proceedings that need to play out to
uh find if that will happen or not but
kind of
where do we go from here maybe like
what's the
risk scenario and then what is kind of
the positive perspective
of where we go from here yeah sure so
yeah as you mentioned um so it is an
extradition extra
hearing so there's a treaty between the
us and the uk and
um it basically says you know if the us
requests
to extradite someone to the us for
whatever grounds um that's fine because
it has to go through a court process
however the caveat is that if they're if
they believe there's a political there's
inherently a political nature to this
trial
then it gets scrapped and so again from
my perspective and many people's
perspectives that have been viewing this
case for years and this particular trial
there's certainly evidence that it's
political in nature
like you know and i think a lot of
people can feel that in their guts they
kind of know and i think that's a big
thing about this case a lot of people
kind of know
there just hasn't been that discussion
in the public or information to kind of
really
go yeah okay okay fair enough now it
makes sense but i think we're coming to
that
um so where we're at now is is a massive
crossroads where we're at is a week out
from the 4th of jan which is the verdict
of this trial which has been going since
february now
um i'll just unpack this a little bit so
um
so um a week out the options on the
table
are uh with trump's last term
um uh you know like last time in play
now he could pardon him
and a lot of people are calling for a
part and that's one way to
to release julian uh and just to to
remember
um he's being extradited to the us so
that he would face
exp the espionage um charges which is
the first time in 102 years
so i think the first time ever the us
has actually placed these these big
espionage um charges on a journalist
and he's facing up to 175 years
if that was to take place so we all kind
of know where that's going to go
now he's facing 23 hours a day solitary
confinement one hour
out it's horrendous right aside from
being in belmarsh
aside from not being given warm clothes
in in the freezing cold
um in london and um you know
i think a lot of people can see that his
treatment in there is just is
really bad he's got a lung condition so
with um
everything going on with covert i know
that the risks were even higher
and there wasn't any special treatment
or anything like that to acknowledge
that so
he's in a pretty dire situation all the
people i've spoken to that have seen him
spoken to him have said mate
this is dire there's not that much time
left to be to be frank
and you know um it's really not looking
good he's got a lovely partner stella
he's been working with amnesty and and
i'm speaking to recently who's
just like you know and their two kids
young kids who barely get to see him as
well who are just doing
absolutely everything they can to try
and um
ensure that his health is kept more than
anything and that's really dire so we
really hope that he can keep up
you know the strength and and move
forward there and that's what we're all
trying to do
now um if the pardon takes place that's
that's a that's huge um
it's a really tough one trump's you know
here it's it's a shot in the dark it's
really hard to know
um when it comes to um you know um biden
let's say that he is extradited on the
fourth that's the verdict
i've been told that this could be a long
lengthy process for 12 to 18 months
afterwards if it's
if there's an appeal um and so
a lot of people don't think he'll last
that long um you know
and then if if the charges were to be
dropped uh by biden in the after the
fourth i think that could be one other
avenue but
that's also a bit of a tough one so i
think the more
discussions that can be have that can be
had with his part his
um team um the better there's been
people in the democratic party like
aoc's expressed concern
you know there's people on on on the
republican party like
you know there's there's ron paul rand
paul there are people from
all sides in the last year i've watched
this as amnesty has become even more
sort of um prevalent um i've really
noticed
talking to different parties how much
this is just not a non-partisan issue
anymore
it's just not non-partisan it's
literally one of those things where
everyone can kind of come together and
go
this is pretty messed up freedom of
speech freedom of expression
um you know the freedom of the press um
they're all kind of
on the line with a case like this
everyone's looking for that one thing
that unites us
biden talks about uniting the population
trump wants to unite the population sure
you know these are the things the
politicians say
there is no better example than this and
it is one of the most important things
for the population to be informed
to hold on to these democratic
principles that we espouse to the world
and hold on to tightly
so i think this is the kind of thing
that we we should all fight for i've
been fighting for this for a long time
uh and watched people who were not even
remotely concerned
in the last year or two slowly slowly
change their change and change their
tune
and in the last week we saw sarah palin
apologize um
you know um i've seen a number a new
york times journalist apologize for
statements he's made about him this is
crucial they said
we know where this stands um larry
sanger the co-founder of wikipedia who
i've been speaking to a really good guy
um and he was very gracious in saying
look i made comments in 2011 i changed
my mind this week this is
so important for everyone and i think
that's what i'm trying to convey more
than anything is that
these are the options on the table this
is why it's important
um and we really need to speak up and
make our voices heard now because that
actually can
after watching it happen working at
amnesty that can make a difference here
absolutely one thing that's interesting
to me uh and even i've done it is
julian assange and edward snowden i
think both are
uh different cases uh different details
different facts
um but many people kind of put them in
the bucket of
these are folks who uh held the powerful
the influential
uh accountable they did it in different
ways um you know
they kind of had their different uh
paths like i said but
is there a world where an outgoing trump
basically says you know what this is a
way to
make a statement and i'm going to not
just pardon assange i'm actually going
to pardon
assange and snowden and maybe others
and kind of you know make that uh
a pushback uh when it comes to freedom
of the press
and the way that both of those
individuals have been treated is that
something that's part of the
conversation
or is it really just hey assange is the
one that's likely to
uh get pardoned if anyone does and so
let's focus the energy there
yeah uh yeah really good question i mean
i think uh looking at history and i've
been looking at this recently to kind of
see if there are any patterns but uh
you know a lot of governments um sorry a
lot of presidents do like to
to pardon people that they they
genuinely have always wanted to
in the last minutes it's kind of like
their last um
chance to add to their legacy uh
as to what kind of a president they were
and probably help out a few mates i
would imagine
um so um with all of that in mind
um i think obama did pardon chelsea
manning and that was a big one
so i actually think and i certainly
don't want to make predictions on this
one but i think that one of them might
be
um and and i think that it would be it
would fall short of trump's
values that he puts forward about
freedom of speech
knowing the repercussions of both of
snowden and assange being
imprisoned or not pardoned i think he
would
do one and the only reason i don't think
he would do both is because people are
in his ear
that's my that's my um that's my
personal opinion
but it's again really hard to predict um
but i think that if you were a president
running on freedom of speech and
expression freedom of the press
and if you were trump condemning fake
news all the time
surely one of them you would think right
you would you would do it so yeah
tough to say but i've got a feeling
let's see we all we can do is prepare
for every outcome in every contingency
ride and um
and give it a crack yeah i uh i tend to
think that there's nothing more real
than uh here's the source material
right read it for yourself and make your
own decision
uh what can people at home do so it's
about a week out until uh
this uh this decision gets made and yes
there may be appeals
depending on how it goes there's pardons
you know there's some kind of these
uh external factors but in the next week
or so what can an individual at home do
is they'll literally get on twitter and
talk about it or the other things that
they can do
yeah um i've thought about the twitter
one quite a bit uh because
in the early days i thought it doesn't
make much difference right but
um i've been at amnesty for for a few
years now and i have genuinely seen the
difference it makes when
a lot of people come together at the
right time
and you know you might think that
trending on twitter things pretty
trivial i used to think it was pretty
trivial
maybe in some ways it still is but i
think that it i've seen assange trending
on twitter every single day
by like one or two days here and there
for the last two weeks and scattered
throughout the year
so um i think it does have impact i
think that twitter is
is actually a small sample size of
public sentiment
but i think that it's an important one
that politicians are aware of
um and do respond to not all the time
but sometimes when
it's important to respond to because of
how it relates to the to the party or
the politician
so um amnesty will be running a twitter
storm
um i believe in in early january
um to condemn this we've been making a
lot of statements on twitter
encouraging retweets we've been working
with people around the world like
celebrities um journalists you know
filmmakers like
mia oliver stone um you know reaching
out to people like
russell brand and noam chomsky who's
showing a lot of support as well and
whoever it may be from all walks of life
once again
to show support on twitter and and
online um
and uh and it does have an impact
because it snowballs and that's a big
word i like to use with amnesty is you
can watch
a campaign start from like a concept and
then watch it slowly snowball gather
steam
and this is why you know um campaigning
and international movements are so
important because they can do that
because you have mass
numbers um and you don't ever think that
your voice isn't important i'll tell you
right now when when i started
campaigning on this
i thought like you know there was there
was about this much of
a good shot to really make traction but
in my mind i was like we can make it
happen let's let's just give this a
really crack and don't let up be
persistent which is one of amnesty's
main values be courageous
have integrity do it the right way and
and
if i look back on the last year and a
half it's been insane how much it's
changed and
for everyone at home even if you are
like kind of on the fence but you think
you're only 60 40 you're more in favor
speak up about it talk to your friends
and family
don't be afraid of conversations that
that that might
um be uncomfortable that's where most
growth and progress happens when you
have uncomfortable conversations right
and with assange that's again one that
i've seen people don't want to touch it
and then once they start learning a bit
more about it they go okay you know what
why not i'm more informed and and and
this is a big
area of passion as well because
information if it's the wrong
information and then you spread
it talking about viruses if you spread
it that goes to that person or that
person that person all of a sudden
everyone
thinks something which is a little
fraction of what the actual issue is
and again like you said source material
that's why it's so important in the
right contexts
and that's why you should be informed
and you should really check yourself
before spreading or talking about
certain information
that applies to not just assange but
everything right and uh
and so yeah i think that um i think that
people should speak up on twitter they
should sign amnesty's petition which i
can share
which was four hundred thousand um and
sydney here representing the global
movement we've been pushing hard for our
aussie
uh you know got four hundred thousand
signatures we handed it over to the u.s
embassy in in sydney
um and it was one of the largest
australian petitions ever signed by
amnesty
um and have had a lot of allies on board
supporting us that you wouldn't expect
so i think that can continue to grow and
just
speak up online i'm sure people have
machine learning
algorithms detecting how often you know
certain keywords are
put up online and okay public sentiment
saying this maybe we should respond to
it
that's the tech side kind of kind of
thinking but uh or talking but i think
that with that in mind just
put it out there you know talk to your
friends and family talk to your local
members
if anyone can assist please feel free to
reach out we can find new networks and
connections to try and
talk to to the different parties and see
if we can come to a to an agreement
because
this is crucial look if you're a
democracy this is one of the principles
we have to stand on
yeah couldn't agree more um for you
personally you're interested also in
bitcoin blockchain crypto
how does that kind of intersect here and
what are your thoughts on that stuff
yeah absolutely um i'm working on an app
actually
um called thinkers and this is actually
in line with with what i've just spoken
about when it comes to quality
information we are at a point in our
history where um where there is an
abundance of information online there's
no question about that
and that has been one of the biggest
talking points of the year
is fake news misinformation these were
buzzwords thrown around
um myself and a team of people who are
very passionate jay
mel anth um lucian wilker uh and dan
we're all very passionate about
um quality information and empowering
people to critically think
and we think the solution is critical
thinking so
um with that um comes in mind a
long-term process of
analyzing the information all the nuance
don't just think black and white
and and um and like any skill with the
community as well it's a lot easier you
can practice it
so what is the context you know et
cetera so we built through
funnily enough um ai and machine
learning an algorithm that detects the
keywords
um in in every article that you read
it's a it's a browser extension that
will be integrated into an app um in
january
so coming very soon and it scans the
page and goes here's who owns this
publication
here's the bias which you can vote on
yourself um which gets aggregated
um you know um he this it's an opinion
piece or it was really new therefore it
could be developing these are all the
things people need to think about when
they consume information
so if you don't have the source material
here's a good way to help you think
through the news you consume every day
now building the app we wanted to build
it with you know trust and privacy in
mind from the
get-go so blockchain being a big factor
um you know having um nfts um that we
would give
when we launch over the coming weeks and
we want to give pioneer nfts to new
users that sign up so that we can reward
quality journalism on era
we want it to be a citizen journalism
platform for local
stories we want to reward critical
thinking we want to reward
um you know uh quality nuanced
discussion not just
the kind of back and forth that we do
see on twitter
and this is again a thing that i've seen
from so many different people going i
can't go on twitter man
i can't talk on this platform i just get
yelled at it's just like
yelling on this side yelling on that
side echo chamber after echo chamber
polarization right
espousing so our solution was
um well-moderated community-driven
um rooms to talk in nuance about a lot
of these conversations and that's going
to be a big task but we think we can
certainly do it
and we want everyone to kind of help and
build with us um
so yeah that was thinkers dot io and
hopefully yeah next month will be very
exciting um we want to introduce a token
in future
and and work towards a decentralized
social media platform for everyone
it's awesome before we get into the
rapid fire questions to uh wrap it up
where can people find you on the
internet
yeah i'm on twitter um you know as well
i am on there so tamira gamage said my
full name
um and uh that's that's i would say
um where i spend a little bit of my time
um i'm not too prominent on any other
social medias just yet i'm i would hope
that
after we get thinkers up and running we
can try and start a new platform and see
what we can do with
maybe a bit more characters so we can
flesh out our thoughts a bit further
before we dive into things
um but yeah please feel free to reach
out to me um
there um or on email directly which is
umira gamage
gmail.com awesome man uh ask the same
two questions everyone before i wrap up
and then you get to ask p1 to finish it
first question is what is the most
important book that you've ever read
that's a good one um not to be corny but
probably the alchemist
i know a lot of people would probably
say that but i i've got to buy my nephew
who's 17 at christmas
sorry i've got to get him a birthday
present um i was going to get it for him
for christmas but i thought you know
what
i'm going to give him the alchemist he's
17. i want him to read it just because
of the anecdotes
and the way to see the world little
signs symbols around
the story and journey that you go on i
just think it's a beautiful
really well written story that you
should keep in the back of your
yeah that's a great great suggestion uh
second question more fun
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
yeah yeah if you ask me about two years
ago i would have said probably not
um like a lot of people drink coco have
had a bit of extra time to look at stuff
i would say yes yeah i
i agree i didn't need coping i didn't
need cover to push me down the rabbit
hole but uh
once you go down man it is uh it's hard
to say that
once you're there you're like are you
kidding me and anyway this year's been
an intro a big one for that right so i
think this is going to continue to grow
over time
i love it uh what's the one question you
have for me to wrap up
um i'm not going to ask if you're
bullish on bitcoin because i know you
are
so i'm gonna say what do you think will
be the biggest um
uh startup trend for 2021
2021 um i think just the continued uh
financialization of assets and uh
and kind of the digitization of those
assets right so you see things like pipe
it's basically taking recurring revenue
and it's turning into a financial asset
i think people are going to find all
kinds of things to kind of financialize
um but also we're going to see every
stockpile currency commodity go from
kind of this electronic q-sip world to a
digital world markets will become 24 7
365 you'll kind of really really break
open accessibility for people around the
world
and kind of just rebuild the financial
system for
a digital global world like you know not
that groundbreaking of an idea but a lot
of work that goes into doing that
um but i think that's kind of where
we're headed uh you know hopefully in
the next couple years for sure
absolutely and i know you
think it's you know as you said not too
groundbreaking but um the more i've
learned about
these systems and where it's headed to
be honest the more you read the more you
learn
you like i said before you kind of just
know this is where it's going to head
it's it's an amazing concept and
technology and i think
i think we're just at the precipice
we're just getting started
i i tend to agree my friend all right
listen thank you so much for doing this
tamira i really think that people are
going to
enjoy hearing more about julian assange
and if this kind of
you know speaks to you you think it's a
big deal please uh please go tell family
friends and
talk about it online we've got about a
week before the decision
and every little bit helps so thanks so
much for uh for coming on and doing this
thank you man my pleasure my pleasure